I don't know about you guys but for me
after I heard the hustle and gretel
story after the gingerbread house and
candy thing I was like did they ever
grow up to become badasses and I for one
I'm thrilled to have the answer to this
burning question Hansel and Gretel witch
hunters so Hansel and Gretel's the story
of Hansel and Gretel you know from the
whole fairy tale thing that were
captured as kids and a little witch was
trying to fatten him up so she could
burn them and eat them and they get away
and what you didn't know is they become
two really attractive badasses yes
they're jeremy renner and hot princess
chick from prince of persia whatever her
name is she is hot witch hunter now and
that's just a cooler title so when this
movie was coming out I was like okay
this could be really awesome or it could
be Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter but
Hansel and Gretel witch hunters and I
gotta say the movie does have its share
of cool and entertaining in that Abraham
Lincoln vampire hunter kind of way
movies exactly what you think it's gonna
be no witches are out there they're
doing bad things I'm kichan 'sons like
the head witch and she's doing really
bad things now Hansel and Gretel with
other gadget REE need to stop them I was
just watching it this one which makes
vines grow than a hostel and Gretel are
shooting their crossbows and I was like
this is what happens when a red white
deck fights a black green deck all is
not right in the world of innistrad my
friends now we get to see it on screen
and although this movie does have its
badass scenes you do see these badass
scenes in the trailer but the trailer
doesn't tell you is that it's not like
an onslaught of them just killing the
out of witches because that would
be awesome but now of course the movie
in it's story arc does slow down halfway
through the movie and you're like
alright well are they killing what's
going on then Jeremy Renner's having a
romance with this hot chick over here
and then hot witch hunter chick finds
this solomon grundy troll dude is all
like this trolls are smart like that
you're like where's this movie going I
get it the movies not supposed to be
Macbeth and I almost argue that it
starts to slow down because it tries to
be real like you're clogging up the
movie man get back to demons dying the
movies really predictable to you'll meet
characters and you're like that's how
this character is gonna play into the
story and you're right oh that's this
hidden thing oh you're right I did
really like his Jeremy Renner has
diabetes they don't call it diabetes but
he totally has diabetes because when he
was captured when he was a kid this
witch was shoving his face with candy
now he's diabetic and I was like cool I
mean granted you don't need to have that
in the story what's the point of it I
have no idea but there's a
he's like yeah you should be diabetic
this witch was shoving his face with
treats trying to get him fat deep down
beneath the surface its Wilford Brimley
the untold story in which case then it's
awesome I mean however you slice it it
seems the thing to do is to take these
fairy tales and make them into tween
romance but they didn't do that
in this one they're like nah we're gonna
make awesome witch hunter badass free
from Diablo 3 there you go but in the
end you still leave going kind of feels
like Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter you
can do with or without this movie you
walk out going I don't know what the
point of that was the end was really
cool and the end is really what you come
to see but sitting through an hour and
40 minutes of a movie to see one scene
at the end that's really awesome yeah it
just makes you go out I don't know if it
was worth it I will say Hansel and
Gretel is a good time if you're drunk
yeah and now it's a party well for
Brimley witch's job baby's alright so
what would be a cool fairy tale that was
turned into a badass movie we got Jack
the Giant Killer coming out so that
doesn't count dude whatever it would be
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more